[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه نبدا بالعناوين
[تصفيق]
في نبره انهزاميه المعارضه تلوم نفسها
والعيب اردوغان على الخساره وتخطيب وده
اوغان صانع الملوك
حرب المعلومات بين موسكو وكاف اسخن من
الميدان وانفجار في اوكرانيا يثير الشكوك
حول اليورانيوم المستقبل
الجيش السوداني في مسؤوليته عن الاعتداء
على السفارات ويؤكد ان الشواهد تورط ادعس
سريع
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
مجلس النواب ينقلب على بشره ويحيله
للتحقيق والامم المتحده تؤكد ان
الانتخابات يجب الا تستبعد احدا
اهلا بكم انتهت الجوله الاولى من
الانتخابات التركيه وبدات مرحله الحساب
الداخلي خاصه في صفوف المعارضه التي لم
تحقق ما كانت تحلم به ايتوغ اتاجي العضو
البارز في حزب الشعب الجمهوري اقر بارتكاب
اخطاء ونواقص في الحمله الانتخابيه لحزب
الشعب الجمهوري وتحالف الامه واعلن ان
التحالف سيخبر الشعب بكل الحقائق حين يحين
الوقت لانه لا يمكن تغيير الخطاب السياسي
للمعارضه في الاسبوعين القادمين الطاجي
لمح ايضا الى وجود الاعيب انتخابيه من قبل
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان المسؤول البارز
قال ان المعارضه نجحت رغم كل شيء في خفض
شعبيه اردوغان وحزب العداله والتنميه
للمره الاولى كما اشار الى وجود اتصالات
مع المرشح الرئاسي الخاسر فنان اوغانا
لكسب اصوات مؤيده في الج القادمه وفيما
يتعلق بشرط اوغان لفك الارتباط مع الاكراد
قال الطاجي ان التحالف لم يقدم للاكراد اي
وعوده وانما هو قائم معهم لا يعد تحالفا
وانما هو اتفاق على مصلحه مشتركه وهي
اسقاط اردوغان
في 28 من مايو سيتنافس مره اخرى على رئاسه
تركيا في جوله اعاده تحدث للمره الاولى
رجب طيب اردوغان من جانب وكمال كالجدار
اوبلو من جانب اخر
وبينهما يقف سنان اوغان فهل سيرجح كفه على
اخرى
هاي اتفاقيه اذا قررنا ان نكون مع تحالف
ما فسيتم التوقيع على اتفاق معهم ونضع
الشروط التي تضمن عدم تقديم اي تنازلات
فيما يتعلق بالحزب الديمقراطي المؤيد
للاكراد لدينا خطوطنا الحمراء لدعم اي
مرشح كمكافحه الارهاب واعاده اللاجئين لقد
تحدثنا عن هذه الشروط من قبل
تكمن قوه كليجدار اوغلو في جوله الاعاده
بقاعدته العلمانيه القوميه الثابته ستدعمه
مهما كلف الامر افكاره اقرب لكتله سنان
اوغان الانتخابيه ويدعم التوجه نحو نظام
حكم برلماني ما يعزز حضوره بين الشباب
اردوغان من جانبه لن يخسر من قاعدته
الانتخابيه اليمينيه الدينيه المحافظه
مهمته الحسابيه اسهل يحتاج فقط الى اعشار
لتجاوز عتبه الخمسين في المئه يبقى
الاقتصاد هو مفتاح صندوق الاقتراع من يقنع
الشباب والاصوات المتردده ان مستقبل تركيا
سيكون اكثر ازدهارا سيجد سبيله نحو كرسي
الرئاسه
وينضم الينا من اسطنبول العربيه طاهر بركه
ومن انقره ايضا وراسل العربيه زيدان زنكلو
اهلا بكما معنا ابدا معك طاهر ماذا عن
استعدادات مرشحي
الرئاسه التركيه للجوله الثانيه
اهلا بك راويه وبالزميل زيدان وبالمشاهدين
بدون شك بدات اليوم بعد ان خفتت قليلا
بالامس حده التراشق الكلامي يمكن ان نقول
انه بدات من جديد الحملات الانتخابيه
واستمعنا للتو الى مقابله للرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان يعدد فيها يعني ضمنيا في
كثير من الاحيان الاخطاء التي وقعت فيها
المعارضه
وبذلك يكون قد افتتح حملته متحدثا عن
زيارته لمناطق الزلزال معيبا على المعارضه
انها اهانه المتضررين من الزلزال
بانتقادها لهم لانهم صوتوا لاردوغان اضافه
الى نيته لقاء الناس في التنقل وعلى ان
يجوب الاسواق والشوارع في انقره واسطنبول
للقاء الناس مجددا هذا ابرز يعني مكان
يقول
الى اتهام المعارضه
يعني او قوله انه الشعب يرفض المؤامرات
كما حصل مع محرم انجي عبر تسريب صوره هو
يتهمها بانها هي التي فعلت ذلك يرفض
التحالف مع المنظمات الارهابيه بسبب دعم
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي للمرشح الرئاسي
كليتشار اوغلو اضافه الى بعض الامور
الاخرى التي يمكن لزميل زيدان ايضا ان
يكون له حصه في اذاعتها على الهواء خاصه
وان المقابله انتهت
كانت على الهواء قبل قليل وكنا نتابعها
فهذا بالنسبه الى الموالاه اما بالنسبه
الى المعارضه فهي تتحدث عن التمسك بالامل
وعن عدم فقدانه وتلوم نفسها ايضا وتحاول
ان تصحح اخطائها وتوجه الانتقادات لبعضها
البعض فيما يتعلق بتهريب اصوات القوميين
بعد التحالف مع المحافظين مثل احمد داود
اوغلو وعلي بابا جان او مثل قبول دعم حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي
المرشح
هل ستستطيع المعارضه ان تقلص يعني ان ترفع
من نتائجها وان تقلص من حجم الخسائر التي
منيت بها في خلال اسبوعين فقط خاصه يعني
مع انتظار الى من ستؤول اليه الاصوات التي
ذهبت في الجوله الاولى الى سينانوجان نعم
انتقل الى زيدان يعني وقع قبل ان نذهب
وتخبرنا عن هذه المقابله واهم ما جاء فيها
مقابله الرئيس التركي الحالي ولكن وقع ما
قاله ايتوغ اتاجي العضو البارز في حزب
الشعب الجمهوري على جمهور المعارضه وايضا
على الجمهور والطرف الاخر
تحيه لك راويه ولزميلي العزيز طاهر ولي
الساده المشاهدين طبعا سابدا بما كتبه
يعني
القياده في حزب الشعب الجمهوري يشرح الحال
التي بدات يعني التي بدات تسود في اجواء
المعارضه التركيه ساستشهد بما قاله كاتب
صحفي من اهم كتاب الصحفيين المعارضين في
مقال نشره هذا اليوم في موقع معارض ويدعى
مراد صابونجو قال لماذا هذا الحداد في
مقرات حزب الشعب الجمهوري ما زال هناك امل
بالتالي هو يعبر عن حال الغضب الموجوده
داخل حزب الشعب الجمهوري نتيجه
التحالفات التي عقدها رئيس حزب الشعب
الجمهوري ومرشح المعرض كمال كالجدار اوكلو
تحديدا مع احزاب الاحزاب المشقه من حزب
العداله والتنميه وهذا وهذه النقطه تحديدا
ركز عليها قيادي بارز في حزب الشعب
الجمهوري في الاجتماع الذي كان للمجلس
التنفيذ التنفيذي المركزي يوم امس هنا في
العاصمه انقره عندما قال اننا بما معناه
ان الحزب الشعبي الجمهوري عول على حزبي
المستقبل
والديمقراطيه والتقدم بقياده احمد داود
اوغلو وعلم باجان في سحب اصوات حزب
العداله والتنميه او سحب الاصوات من حزب
العداله والتنميه لكن الذي جرى العكس
هؤلاء الحزبين او مرشحين من الحزبين اضافه
الى مرشحين من حزب السعاده والحزب
الديمقراطي هم موجودين هؤلاء الاحزاب
الاربعه في الطاوله السداسيه دخلوا في
قوائم حزب الشعب الجمهوري وماذا كانت
النتيجه ارتفعت اصوات الحزب فقط اثنان
واثنين فاصله سبعه
مقابل
وهي الزياده التي حصل عليها الحزب في
البرلمان عن الجوله الماضيه بينما اردوغان
استطاع باستقطاب حزب واحد وهو حزب الرفاه
من جديد بقياده فاتح اربكان ان يحصل على
2.8% بدل الاربع احزاب التي تحالف
كماله الجدار وهذا الحديث الذي كان دائرا
يوم امس في مقرات حزب الشعب الجمهوري
وايضا مات نقلت ما تناقلته صحافه الصحافه
المقربه من حزب الشعب الجمهوري بالعوده
الى كلمه الرئيس التركي والمقابله
المتلفزه لرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان هو
بدا اضافه الى ما ذكره الزميل طاهر تحدث
عن نقطه مهمه وهي ما كنا نتحدث عنه في
السابق الموضوع القلق في حال وصلت
المعارضه الى الرئاسه واي كميه الجدار
اوغلو والبرلمان بات اللئان بيد تحالف
الشعب والرئيس اردوغان اردوغان شرح هذه
النقطه واراد ايصال رساله الناخبين لا
تجعلوا هناك لا تجعلوا او لا تخلق تعارضا
ما بين السلطه التنفيذيه والسلطه
التشريعيه وضرب مثال بلديتي اسطنبول
وانقره عندما قال ان رئاسه البلديتين بيد
حزب الشعب الجمهوري لكن المجالس البلديه
والبلديات المح بيدنا اشياء يعني في اشاره
غير مباشره الى ان العمل في المدينتين
تراجع بشكل كبير وهذا يعني هذه النقطه
سيستغلها بشكل كبير
اردوغان وقال يجب ان يكون هناك انسجام بين
السلطه التشريعيه والسلطه التنفيذيه حتى
يكون العمل سلسا ولا يوجد هناك اي تعارض
في المصالح اصلا زيدان بعد قليل سيكون
لدينا ملف اقتصادي حول ما اذا وصل اردوغان
او بقي بالرئاسه وما حظوظ ايضا
ولكن اعود اليك طاهر حسب المؤشرات وحسب
ايضا
الخطابات ومن حديثك مع الناس اصوات سنان
اوغان لمن يعني
قد تذهب برايك
هناك مشكله في هذا الموضوع يعني هو هناك
عده سيناريوهات محتمله او المشكله الاولى
ان يعني يجب على الجميع ان يتذكر دائما
بان الاصوات التي ذهبت الى كما كنا نقول
في الايام الماضيه حصل على اكثر من 5% قد
لا تكون بجميعها لشخصه او لبرنامجه وانما
يعني هروبا من المرشحين الاخرين بسبب
تحالفاتهما الانتخابيه اذا هذه نقطه
النقطه الثانيه لمن هو سيجير اصواته هل
سيعلن يعني هل سيكون هناك موقفا هل سيكون
هناك موقف واضح جدا
يعلنه يعني يحاول ان يوجه به الناخبين وهل
في السيناريو الثالث سيلتزم هؤلاء
الناخبون بكل ما يقول يعني الايام المقبله
بدون ستبين هذا الموضوع في يعني نقطه ايضا
مهمه يجب ان نشير اليها هي كيف ستعالج
الموالاه اوجه الخلل فيما حصلت عليه من
اصوات تحدثنا في هذه المره وفي مرات سابقه
عن يعني نقاط الضعف عند المعارضه ومالت
اليها ارقامها ايضا الموالاه يؤخذ عليها
الان ثلاثه امور باختصار شديد الاول يعني
الماخذ الاول هو ان الرئيس اردوغان لم
يستطع ان يحسم من الجوله الاولى انه خسر
اسطنبول وانقر حسابيا يعني ولو كانت
الارقام او الفوارق قليله
اضافه الى التراجع في حزب العداله
والتنميه والموالاه التراجع الذي حصل في
البرلمان في عدد المقاعد التي حصلوا عليها
اذا هذه ايضا نقاط مهمه يقول الجميع ايضا
حتى الرئيس اردوغان قال لم اكن استمع بسبب
سوء الصوت الى زميل زيدان لا اعرف اذا ذكر
ذلك ذكر انه هو ينظر في اخطاء او الموالاه
ستنظر في الاخطاء التي حصلت حتى حصل هذا
التراجع في البرلمان اذا الكثير من العمل
عند الجبهتين في الاسبوعين القادمين قبل
انتخابات 28 من مايو راويه شكرا جزيلا لك
مفضلة العربيه طاهر بركه وايضا مراسل
العربيه زيدان
خيبه امل اصيب بها المستثمرون في تركيا
بعد الاعلان عن نتائج الدوره الاولى من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه استطلاعات
الراي التي كانت ترجح فوز المعارضه اعطت
جرعه من الامل للمستثمرين بامكانيه تغير
السياسات الاقتصاديه لتركيا التي عصفت
بالليره وزادت من نسبه التضخم ردوا الفعل
الاولي للسوق على نتائج الانتخابات كان
بتراجع الليره التركيه الى ادنى مستوى لها
في شهرين الى مستوى
19.70 مقابل او مقابل الدولار وهو مستوى
غير بعيد عن
19.8 تحديدا هو الرقم الذي سجلته العمله
التركيه بعد زلزال فبراير الماضي بشكل عام
تراجعت الليره 5% منذ بدايه العام كما
انها فقدت حوالي 95% من قيمتها على مدار
خمسه عشره عاما الماضيه وكانت موديز
للتصنيف الائتماني قالت الترجيح فوز
اردوغان سيعني استمرار السياسات
الاقتصاديه غير التقليديه ما سيضغط على
العمله المحليه فضلا عن زياده فرص ارتفاع
التضخم الذي تجاوز بالفعل اربعين في المئه
معدله اخرى تواجه تركيا هي العجز الكبير
في الحساب الجاري والذي وصل الى مستوى
قياسي بلغ 24 مليار دولار في الربع الاول
من هذا العام مع توقعات بوصوله الى اربعين
مليارا بنهايه العام العجز هذا سيدفع
تركيا لمحاوله العثور على مليارات
الدولارات لتمويل العجز المتزايد ويمكن
تحقيق الامر جزئيا من خلال الاستمرار في
الاستفاده من مخزون تركيا المتضائل من
احتياطات العملات الاجنبيه في هذا السياق
الميزانيات العموميه للدوله والبنك
المركزي انخفضت الى مستويات متدنيه للغايه
ما يجعل احتياطيات النقد الاجنبي للبنك
غير ك
ولتغطيه اي احتياجات لاعاده تمويل النقد
الاجنبي الكبيره للبلاد مثلا محللون
اقتصاديون قالوا لصحيفه البريطانيه ان
تركيا بسياساتها الاقتصاديه الحاليه
ستستمر في السير على حافه الهاويه وان
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في حال حصوله على
ولايه جديده سيكون مضطرا بشكل او باخر
لتغيير سياسته الاقتصاديه هل هذا الموضوع
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول الخبير التركي
الخبير الاقتصادي
رحمة انجيكارا اهلا بك معنا سيد
رحمي يعني
التضخم واعباء المعيشه وانهيار قيمه
الليره التركيه هي اعباء عاشها جميع
الاتراك ان كانوا مع اردوغان او مع كليتش
دور من
صوتوا لاردوغان لماذا صوتوا له مع انهم
عاشوا كل هذه المعاناه الاقتصاديه
لفتره تزيد عن عقدين من الزمن
ولعله قد يكون على مرمى حجر من تولي دوره
اخرى في الرئاسه لكن لا يعد اي من اردوغان
او كردستان في موضع يمكن من خلاله القول
بانه ما حقق فوزا كاسحا في هذه الانتخاب
في الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات الى حين
انتظار الجوله المقبله التي سوف تحدث في
28 من في شهر مايو وهناك تراشق في
الاتهامات بين الطرفين حول الضعف الاقتصاد
وتهاوي اللير التركيه لمساوات القياسيه
الامر الذي كان قد جعل من الليره التركيه
تنخفض في مؤشرات العملات الى اكثر من سته
في المئه
بعيده الانتخابات
الجوله الاولى ما حدا بالرئيس التركي
للحديثي عن العمل
لرفع
مستوياتها رغم رغم النسب المئويه التي
حققها كل من الطرفين ونعلم ان
ان كافه المستثمرين يشعرون بحاله من خيبه
الامل في ظل
السياسه التقليديه التي تبناها الرئيس
التركي اردوغان دون ان تقديم اي التزامات
تجاهها معالجه مشاكل التضخم والنكبات
الاقتصاديه التي عاشتها تركيا وكذلك
الاسواق الماليه في تركيا تظهر مدى الضعف
التبادل التبادلات الماليه
وتراجع مخزوني البنك المركزي بواقع اكثر
من 9% من القطع الاجنبي والعملات الاجنبيه
وان هذه المساله قد يتم النظر بها في
اعقاب الجوله الثانيه بين اردوغان وكل
دستور انخفاض
القدره الشرائيه للمواطنين الاتراك في ظل
تراجع العمله التركيه مقابل الدولار
الامريكي كان كان نتيجه للاحداث التي وقعت
في العام الماضي التي تسببت بها اردوغان
في تبنيه لسياسته التقليديه الامر الذي
زاد من التضخم وهذا ما حدا بالاعداد
الكبيره من المستثمرين في تركيا
دفعي التكاليف في تامين باهظه
بسبب ما فرضته الحكومه من اجور مرتفعه
التي وصلت الى سبعه في المئه
وهي الاعلى من نوعها في عمليات التبادل
التجاريه
بالمقارنه وفقا لمؤشرات الاسواق وكالات
الائتمان الاقتصاديه تقول بان الفوز
للمعارضه يؤمل منه بانه سوف
يفتح صفحه جديده
للتبني سياسات اقتصاديه اذا ما نفذت
بطريقه فعاله فسوف تعود باثر ايجابي على
الملف الائتماني للبلاد لكن حتى اللحظه لا
يبدو بانه وبصوره النسبيه بان
تمت مؤشرات توحي
بتغيير النظره الاقتصاديه في ظل التقلبات
التي يعيشها الاقتصاد التركي والاسواق
الماليه التركيه
وفي نهايه العام 2021 ومنذ بدات نسب
التضخم بالارتفاع وصعود اردوغان وتركيا
بالتعاون مع المصرف المركزي على تبني
سياسه
لرده مستويات التضخم
من اجل احتوائي التضخم والازمه ومؤشرات
انفاق المستهلكين ايضا ارتفعت بوقع خمسه
في المئه وكذلك في شهر ابريل وهذا وفقا
لمؤسسات الاحصاء التركيه
التي ظهرت ان الاسواق الناشئه وقد تاثرت
في ظل اوضاع تضخم العالميه لكن واذا ما
فاز الرئيس التركي اردوغان فانه سوف يتبنى
نفس السيناريو لكن عليه ان يعمل على ضمان
السوق الاقتصادي والاسواق الماليه في
تركيا
وعدم الاستمرار
بمساله
بمساله اسعار الفائده التي تم تبنيها
ورفعها الامر الذي دفع بالتضخم
بالارتفاع والانخفاض قدرتي القوه الشرائيه
للعمله التركيه ان اداء اردوغان على
المستوى الاقتصادي
لم يعودوا بتحقيق نتائج اقتصاديه كبيره
على البلاد رغم انه قد تطرق لهذه المساله
استطلاعات الرايق بين الانتخابات قد اظهرت
وجهات نظر متقابله في مساله الملف
الاقتصادي لكل من المرشحين لكن قبل
الانتخابات ووفقا لنتائج التي ظهرت يوم
الجمعه كان هناك نسبه
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا الخبير الاقتصادي
التركي رحمي انشكار حدثنا من اسطنبول
وتتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل
سعيا لرفع روح المعنويه قائد القوات
البريه الاوكرانيه يزور محيطه بخموت ويقلد
جنوده اوسمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قالت نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه جانا مليار أنا الجيش
الاوكراني ارغم القوات الروسيه على التخلي
عن اجزاء من محيط باخمه شرق البلاده وانها
حررت حوالي عشرين كيلو مترا مربعا من شمال
وجنوب ضواحي المدينه متهمه القوات الروسيه
بتدمير المدينه بشكل كامل
هذا وزاره قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
الجنرال
الجنود الذين يقاتلون في منطقه باخموت
ومنح بعضهم اوسمه
انا كنت تقربوننا من انتصارنا العام
وتقدمون امكانيه استعداد مجموعات عسكريه
اخرى لتشارك في العمليات الهجوميه في
باخموت ان ممتن لكم وللجهود التي تبذلونها
اتمنى لكم العوده الى وحداتكم العسكريه
احياء واصحاء بعد استكمال كل مهامكم
العسكريه المجد لاوكرانيا
وقع في ملف اوكرانيا في العالم باسره كان
ينتظر الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد تحدثنا عن
هجوم الشتاء ولاحقا مع بدايات العام
الجاري كان الحديث عن هجوم الربيع وهذا
الفصل شارف على نهايته لكن لماذا استغرق
الاستعداد للهجوم وقتا طويلا
صحيفه واشنطن بوست قالت ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تواجه تحديا معقدا لكنها تمتلك
ميزتين رئيسيتين هما اختيار وقتي ومكان
الهجوم الامر الاصعب لاوكرانيا هو توليد
القوه القتاليه اللازمه للهجوم اضافه
لمزاملتها مع الدعم المستمر من الغرب
اوكرانيا كبلد كبير جغرافيا ومع طول جبهات
القتال يتطلب ذلك تنسيقا كبيرا بين الفرق
المختلفه ايضا تحتاج العمليات الهجوميه
لمزيد من القوات اضافه لخطوط امداد اطول
واكثر امانا واشنطن بوست اشارت الى ان
اوكرانيا ستكون بحاجه للاستعداد لمرحله ما
بعد المعارك الاوليه فسيحتاج المدنيون
الاوكرانيون في الاراضي المستعاده لمساعده
انسانيه كما ان عمليات ازاله الالغام
ستكون واسعه النطاق اخيرا يجب على الناتو
وحلفاء اوكرانيا ان يكونوا مستعدين
لمواصله دعم اوكرانيا ربما الى اجل غير
مسمى حتى نهايه الحرب
قال مسؤول امريكي في حديث
ان احد انظمه للدفاع الجوي تعرض لاضرار
على الارجح لكن لم يتم تدميره بعده هجوم
صاروخير
وقال المسؤول ان واشنطن لا تزال تقيم حجم
الضرر الذي اصاب النظام كما نقلت سي ان ان
عن مسؤولين قولهم ان اوكرانيا بدات
باستخدام صواريخ ستورم شادو المقدمه من
بريطانيا لضرب اهداف روسيه
ومع ارتفاع حده المعارك بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه تتضارب الروايات بشان
العمليات العسكريه التي تجري في المعارك
على جبهات عده حيث تتخذ حرب المعلومات
التي تتضمن هذه العمليات جمع المعلومات
حول الخصم ثم ادارتها واعاده تحليلها
ونشرها اعلاميا بطريقه مشوهه ومضلله بهدف
التاثير سلبا على الصوره الذهنيه للخصم
ليله مشتعله وروايتان متضاربتان لمعركه
كيف الجويه الان الجيش الاوكراني عن اسقاط
18 صاروخا روسيا في هجمه وصفت
بالاستثنائيه اعلان نفته روسيا مؤكده ان
ضرباتها الدقيقه دمرت دفاعات كييف الجويه
كما دمرت منظومه باتريوس امريكيه وذخيره
غربيه ومخازن اسلحه قائله انها اعترضت
سبعه صواريخ من طراز ستوم شادو بريطانيه
[موسيقى]
على الارض لا يوجد ما يثبت ايا من
الادعاءات السابقه بل العكس
[تصفيق]
اذ عمد كل طرف منذ بدايه الحرب الى عرض
بيانات تؤكد تقدمه على حساب الاخر تحت ما
تعرف بحرب المعلومات ففي الاشهر الاولى
وتحديدا يونيو من العام الماضي دعت روسيا
سياده الجويه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه بعد
تدمير اسطولها الجوي الادعاء لن يد طويلا
تم ضحضه برص طائرات اوكرانيه تنفذ هجمات
على مناطق حدوديه بالقرب من خط المواجهه
في
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا من القاهره الدكتور احمد
عليبه الباحث في وحده الدراسات الامنيه
والعسكريه في مركز الاهرام للدراسات
السياسيه اهلا بك معنا السيد احمد يعني
التصريحات الروسيه تتحدث عن تدمير منظومه
وهو الذي اكده الجانب الامريكي منذ قليل
وصواريخ بريطانيه بعيده المدى ايضا
اوكران بالمقابل يتحدثون عن اسقاط صواريخ
فرد صوتيا بهذه الحاله باطار هذه الحرب
الكلاميه والتصريحات المتبادله بين
الطرفين كيف يمكننا تبيان الحقيقه من
التضليل الاعلامي والعسكري
الحقيقه انه الحرب الكلاميه
والحرب المعلومات هي واحده من سمه هذه
الحرب وسمت الحروب عموما لكن مساله انه
يتم التباين مما جرى انا اعتقد ان هذه
ايضا مساله صعبه لحد كبير لانه ما فيش شرف
هيكشف اوراقه للطرف الاخر حتى لو تم
التاكيد على انه تم استهداف منظومه وانا
اميل ايضا الى هذا الامر خاصه الجانب
الامريكي اللي بيعترف بذلك لكن هل تمت
اصابتها بصاروخ كنجال ام بصاروخ كليبر ام
بدرانز ام بصاروخ اسكندر
واي مكان تمت اصابتها في اذا كانت مركبه
من ثلاث وحدات يعني هل وحده الاطلاق هل
وحده التحكم ايضا ام اي بطاريه من
البطاريات التي تستخدم ايضا في عمليه
التشغيل وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه المهم هنا
هو السياق الذي جرت في عمليه الاستهداف
بشكل او باخر فكره تفنيد الروايه لا يمكن
ان نتحدث عن روايه في كل مره بشكل يعني
مطلق لانه كل حدث له تفاصيل مختلف عن
الاخر بمعنى انه انا اعتقد ان روسيا اجادت
ضربه الامس بشكل كبير لانها يعني اطلقت
النظم متعدده من انواع متعدده من الصواريخ
وايضا طائرات الترانز شاهد 136 الهدف هنا
هو اولا التشتيت صحيح ان المنظومه تستطيع
ان تتعامل مع نحو خمسين هدف ربما يكون
هناك مبالغه في الرقم لكن تم الاختبار على
هذا النحو ايضا كان هناك اتجاه روسي واضح
لاستخدام صواريخ نوعيه الاسكندر والكنغال
هي ايضا صواريخ نوعيه بالنسبه
ل يعني المقارنات الخاصه بالصواريخ ولا
تستخدم
الاهداف اصطياد اهداف استراتيجيه عاليه
المستوى لا يمكن ان تضحي روسيا بهذا القدر
من الصواريخ
اذا كانت هناك بالفعل اهداف مهمه تريد ان
تستهدفها لكن ايضا لدينا مؤشرات هناك
تراجع في قدرات المنظومات الامريكيه على
الرغم من التحسينات التي ادخلت على هذه
المنظومات منظومه
الباتروت باكستري تم تحسينها اضيفت اليها
واحده من المفترض ان هذه الوحده تقلد زمن
التسارع للاعتراض بمقدار الثلث وهي تحتاج
الى مره ونصف فقط لعمليه الاعتراض ومع ذلك
هناك اخفاق المساله الاخرى انه منظومه هاي
مارس ايضا ربما تمكنت روسيا في الفتره
الاخيره وباعتراف امريكا ايضا وفقا
لتقديرات معهد الحرب الامريكي لانه هناك
قدرات روسيه تمكنت من التشويش على هذه
المنظومه وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه القدرات
الدفاع وبالتالي ايضا يمكن ان نفهم انه
ضمن جوله رئيسكي الى اوروبا هو الحديث مره
اخرى عن منظومات الدفاع
المانيا كانت ستزود الجانب الاوكراني
بمنظومه ايروس تي هناك ايضا حديث الان على
انه المنظومه لن تكون النسخه التقليديه
ولكن نسخه
الاكثر تقدما وتتحرك ايضا في اتجاه ارض جو
ليس جو جو مصر المنظومه القديمه التي كان
يتم الاتفاق عليها اولا ولهذا تاخرت عمليه
تسب حتى الان اذا هناك مشكله في مساله
المنظومات الدفاعيه الموجوده في اوكرانيا
في هذه المرحله هذا لا يقلل من قيمه ولا
يقلل ايضا من قيمه الصواريخ الروسيه لكن
هناك مبالغه منها الجانبين ما الجانب
الروسي يرى انه الصواريخ يعني
ولكن سنتحدث عن نقطه ايضا مهمه جدا عن
انفجار ضخم وقع السبت في مستودع للذخيره
في مدينه
خيميليانسكي غربي اوكرانيا قيل انه حدث
فجر يوم السبت وشكل ما يشبه سحابه تذكرنا
بالانفج النوويه ونشاهد هذه الصور مسيرات
روسيه استهدفت بحسب الانباء مخازن اسلحه
تابعه للجيش الاوكراني ما تسبب في
انفجارين هائلين نجم عنهما اصابه اكثر من
20 شخصا متابع اللقطات قبل ان نستكمل
قوات الانفجار اعادت للاذهان ملف قذائف
اليورانيوم المنظم التي اعلنت بريطانيا
انها سترسلها الى اوكرانيا بافتراض ان
الانفجار ضم بعضا من قذائف اليورانيوم
المنضب فما الذي سيحدث في البدايه يستخدم
اليورانيوم المستنفذ في تصنيع الذخائر
بهدف اختراق الدروع مثل تلك الموجوده في
الدبابات والتي يصعب اختراقها احيانا
بالقذائف التقليديه انفجار هذه القذائف
يجعل اليورانيوم المنظم يشتعل ويتفكك الى
اجزاء تشكل رذا من الجسيمات الدقيقه
ويعتبر اليورانيوم المنظم اقل نشاطا
اشعاعيا من اليورانيوم الطبيعي لكن رغم
ضعف نشاطه الاشعاعي فان هذا الاشعاع يستمر
لالاف السنوات الخطر الرئيسي المرتبط
بذخائر اليورانيوم المستنفذ يتمثل في
استنشاق جسيميات الماده المشعه بعد
الانفجار ومثل اي ماده مشعه هناك خطر
الاصابه بالسرطان من التعرض للاشعاع
المنبعث من اليورانيوم الطبيعي وايضا
المستنفذ التعرض للجسيميات عن طريق
الاستنشاق سيضر بالكلى والكبد والقلب كما
انه سيزيد من خطر الاصابه بسرطان الرئه
والدماغ ايضا بالامكان ان ننتقل او تنتقل
هذه الجسيمات من خلال انتقال اليورانيوم
المنظم الموجود في التربه الى المياه
السطحيه والجوفيه التي يت البشر
والحيوانات ايضا وكذلك سيؤدي وجود
اليورانيوم المنظم الموجود في التربه
وايضا في المياه الى ان تمتصه النباتات
ماء سينتقل وسينقله بطريقه اخرى للبشر عند
تناول الخضار والفاكهه من جديد ينضم الينا
من القاهره الدكتور احمد عليبه دكتور احمد
من خلال ما شاهدته من صور تقديرك لما رايت
بمدينه خميليانس هل ما شاهدناه هو
يورانيوم منضب
يعني وفقا للشكل الظاهري وبعض التقارير
اللي تحدثت يعني خسها من الجانب الروسي
هناك قناعه بانه هذا كان بالفعل مخزن
لكن انا اعتقد انه لم يتم استهدافه كما
قيل بالطائره الدرونز باستخدام الدرونز
ولكن ايضا باستخدام صواريخ وعلاجات روسيا
الاستخدام كنجال في اكثر من مره للوصول
الى مخازن تحت الارض ربما تصل العمق حوالي
150 متر
لكن من الواضح انه هذا المخزن كان قريب من
سطح الارض وانه الضربه ايضا كانت كبيره
حتى يحدث هذا الانفجار لكن انا امير الى
الروايه التي يعني تقول بانه بالفعل كان
هذا السلع لماذا لانه روسيا بدات تعمل على
تدفق يعني
عدد كبير او عشرات من الدبابات التي 92
المح
وبالتالي كان يعني ضمن مساله الاستعداد
للمرحله المقبله من نجوم الربيع ان يكون
هذا المخزون موجود هذه المساله بمنتهى
السهوله لكن من الواضح ايضا انها يعني
ضربه قويه للجانب الروسي ان يصل الى
استكشاف موقع المخزن موجود في غرب
اوكرانيا
وايضا انه يتم تدميره بهذا الشكل ربما سوف
يكون من الصعوبه بمكان القولون بان هناك
مخازن اخرى لهذا الموضوع
ضربه استخباريه ان كانت صحيحه بشكل او
باخر لكن الصور تفيد بهذا الامر في ظني
الى حد كبير شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من القاهره
الدكتور احمد عليبه الباحث في وحده
الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه في مركز
الاهرامي للدراسات السياسيه
قل المدعي العام في مكتب مكافحه الفساد في
اوكرانيا او الكسندر اوميتشينكو ان سلطات
انفاذ القانون احتاجت رئيس المحكمه العليا
في البلاد في تحقيق رشا وبقيمه 2.7 مليون
دولار
في هذا الوقت تم اعتقال رئيس المحكمه
العليا ويجري اتخاذ تدابير للتحقق من
الاشخاص الاخرين وتوردهم في الجريمه
الجنائيه
قال كبير الجمهوريين في مجلس في لجنه مجلس
الشيوخ للعلاقات الخارجيه جمريش قال ان
البيت الابيض لا يفكر ابدا في روسيا حتى
تتخذ موسكو خطوه ولم يتصرف ابدا بشكل
استباقي لاجبار الكريم على الاستجابه
للمبادرات الامريكيه واضاف ريش ان بوتين
يعرف انه يستطيع التهديد باستخدام الاسلحه
النوويه دون اي رد ملموسه من الغرب
اعلنا الجيش السوداني انه لا يتحمل
مسؤوليه نهب مقر السفرات ان ظروف الحرف في
السودان منعت قوات الامن من حمايه البعثات
الدبلوماسيه متهما قوات الدعم السريع
بالهجمات التي تقع على السفارات ناسبا ذلك
لشهود اعيننا
ورصدت العربيه مطالبات اكثر من 300 سوداني
من حمله الجوازات الغربيه العالقين بمدينه
بورسودان جراء المواجهات التي دخلت شهرها
الثاني
ونحن اكثر من اسبوعين جينا هنا في
بورسودان وجينا كونه عشان يشيلوني يودونا
بلداننا وما في اي حاجه حاصله اكتر من 300
شخص
سفارات بريطانيه امريكيه فرنسيه اي كل
الجاليات الاوروبيه موجوده هنا طالبنا
سفاراتنا بانه تجلينا لانه في كانوا ناس
قبل كده ونحن كنا عالقين لغايه ما وصلنا
لغايه هنا خاطبنا
نحن بنطالب تاني السفارات الناتج لنا كل
وصلنا هنا في ظروف ظاهره وكل العالم ده
يعلم بها رسالتنا رساله واحده دارينا
الامم المتحده تجلينا لدوله امنه
[موسيقى]
صوت مجلس النواب الليبي لصالح ايقاف رئيس
الحكومه المكلفه فتحي باشاغه واحالاته
للتحقيق وكلف وزير الماليه اسامه حماد
بتسيير مهامه وكان باشاغا كلف في وقت سابق
نائبه علي القطران بتسير مهام مجلس
الوزراء قبل ان تحجب الثقه عنه
الى ذلك دعا المجلس الاعلى للدوله في
ليبيا مجلس النواب للاتفاق على حكومه
موحده لاجراء الانتخابات معتبرا ان مهمه
هذه الحكومه ستكون انهاء المرحله
الانتقاليه كما دعا رئيس المجلس للالتفات
الى مصلحه الدوله العليا عبر وضع خارطه
الطريق للانتخابات
قبل ذلك شدد المبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا عبد
الله بتيل في لقاء مع العربيه على ضروره
اشراك اصحاب المصلحه كافه في العمليات
الانتخابيه
وهذه القضايا لاكثر من سنتين
واذا كان هناك لي حسنه وكذلك التزام سياسي
واخلاقي حقيقي وكذلك اذا ما اتخذ القرار
بالاستجابه لنداء الشعبي الليبي فلا ارى
اي سبب يمنع عقده هذه الانتخابات وطبعا
الانتخابات لا تقتصر على القانون
الانتخابي وكذلك هي لا تقتصر على
الاتفاقات السياسيه كما انها لا تخص فقط
القاعده الدستوريه وانما تعني اشراك الشعب
الليبي وكذلك كافه الاطراف ذات العلاقه
ولذلك قلت بانه ينبغي علينا اشراك كافه
اصحاب المصلحه بما في ذلك على سبيل المثال
القاده الامنيين
وردا على سؤال للعربيه بشان ترشح حفتر
وسيف الاسلام القذافي للانتخابات قلبتيه
لي انه لا يجب استثناء احد
ما المقاربه الامميه المتعلقه بشروط
الترشح هل من المفترض او من الضروري ان
يسمح للعسكريين ولوجوه النظام السابق بان
يترشحوا للرئاسيات ونقصد هنا بالتاكيد
خليفه حفتر سيف الاسلام القذافي وغيرهم من
الشخصيات بالتاكيد
ادركوا ان سمت قضايا جدليه بما في ذلك
معايير الترشح للانتخابات
ولكن فيما يخص بعثه الامم المتحده لدعم في
ليبيا
الانتخابات حتى تكون
ممثله لاراده الشعب الليبي ومن اجل توصل
الى استقرار بفضل هذه الانتخابات هذه
الانتخابات يجب ان لا تستثني احدا
اغلى شحنه موز في ايطاليا حاويه ثانيه
اقترب ثمنهما من المليار دولار تابعونا
بعد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد عبر اجتماع لجنه الامن
القومي في باكستان عن تضامنه الكامل مع
القوات المسلحه في اعقاب اعمال الشغب
والتخريب التي اعقبت اعتقال رئيس الوزراء
السابق عمران خان وابدى الاجتماع وتاييده
لبيان الجيش بمحاكمه مخططي ومنفذي
الاعتداءات
اجتماع للمطبخ الامني للحكومه الباكستانيه
بمشاركه القيادتين السياسيه والعسكريه
الاجتماع جدد التنديد باعمال الشغب
والتخريب التي طالت منشات ومرافق خاصه
وعامه من بينها مرافق التابعه للجيش
متواعدا مخطط ومنفذ الهجمات باجراءات
صارمه
اجتماع لجنه الامن القومي يعبر عن تضامنه
مع الجيش الباكستاني ويدين هذه الحوادث
سياخذ القانون مجراه وسنتخذ الاجراءات
القانونيه والاداريه اللازمه لمنع تكرار
ما جرى لن تتم معاقبه اي شخص دون مبرر
لكننا لن نتهاون مع المذنبين ممن خططوا
وحرضوا على التخريب هم بلا شكل مذنبون
بالارهاب
عمران خان في اي صله له ولحزبه باحداث
الشغب والتخريب التي تلت اعتقانه متهما في
المقابل عناصر في الامن بافعالها لتبرير
ما وصفها بالحمله الامنيه ضد قاده ونشطاء
حزبه داعيا الى تشكيل لجنه تحقيق مستقله
ومجددا دعوه انصاره للتظاهر
لقد حان الوقت للتضحيه من اجل الحريه
الحقيقيه ومقاومه ما يقوم به بعض الاف من
عناصر الشرطه فعندما يرفض الشعب هذه
القسوه كما رفض النيل من الدستور والقضاء
ويطالب باختيار ممثلي عندها ستصبحون
احرارا اكسروا صنم الخوف وعندما ادعوكم
للنزول للشارع تظاهروا سلميه لنيل حقوقكم
وحرياتكم
وفيما يواجه عمران خان وقاده حزبه قائمه
طويله من القضايا والبلاغات اصدر مجلس
النواب قرارا للتضامن مع الجيش وادانه
مرتكبي اعمال الشغب فيما مسؤولون حكوميون
وجود اي خطه لحظر حزب الانصاف من العمل
السياسي
الاتهامات ضده او استمرار التصعيد
والمواجهه وتحمل اي عواقب قد تطال قاده
حزمه وربما تماسكه عبد الرحمن المزيني
العربيه اسلام اباد
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاثناء مشاهدينا القوات
الاسرائيليه تقتحم شرق مدينه نابلس وتشتبك
مع الفلسطينيين تصريح اليوم يجب توخي
الحذر عند استخدام تطبيقات الذكاء
الاصطناعي في استشارات الرعايه الصحيه
التصريح هو لمنظمه الصحه العالميه التي
حضرت من ان بيانات الذكاء الاصطناعي قد
تستخدم بنوع من التحيز او استخدامها انضمت
الصحه العالميه اذا لهيئات دوليه كثيره لا
تمدح في الذكاء الاصطناعي وانما تحذر منهم
فيديو اليوم من ايطاليا واغلى شحنه موز
على الاطلاق ما كان منتظرا وصوله الى
ميناء كلابيليا هو حاويه ثاني مبردتان
تحميلات كميات كبيره من الموز من
الاكوادور لكن ما كان موجودا في الحقيقه
هو
2700 كيلو جراما من الكوكايين شديد النقاء
قيمتها 800 مليون يورو اما بطل هذا الكشف
فهو اجهزه مسح متخصصه بالاضافه الى كلب
بوليسي متخصص يدعى جويل ساره بطلا في
ايطاليا لكنه بالتاكيد صار مكروها لدى من
ارسل الشحنه من الاكوادور
[موسيقى]
ما صوره اليوم فهي من انغولا حيث كررت
الصوره الف مره اطباء الصحه العالميه
يبحثون عن اثار لفيروس مره قد يكون الايدز
وهذه المره
وككل مره يقف المتهمون في صفوف ينتظرون ما
يشبه الادانه او قرارا بالافراج اقدام
اتعبها الوقوف وقلوب انهكها الانتظار وهم
يعلمون جيدا ان من جاءوا لن يكتشفوا
الفيروس الحقيقي الذي تعاني منه القاره
فيروس انسيانا
نكتفي بهذا القدر من الملفات ولكن الزميله
ميسو ستفتح معكم المزيد منها في اخبار
الساعه مساء الخير ميسون مساء الخير راويه
طبعا نحن سنبدا بموضوع اقرار واشنطن بتضرر
نظام باتريوت في هجوم روسيه على كيف
الموضوع الثاني تحريك الاسماء الليبيه
ايضا لدينا الانتخابات التركيه وجوله
الاعاده ومؤشرات بدء هذه الحمله
الانتخابيه الجديده حتى اقرار هذه
الانتخابات او اجراء هذه الانتخابات بعد
اسبوعين واخيرا تبرئه تقرير المدعي العام
لترامب
بعلاقته مع روسيا والعديد من الاخبار
نتمنى ان تتابعينا تفضلي لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات